Did people curse in the real
Deadwood like on HBO's "Deadwood"?
How did the movie get made 13 years
after the show ended? How did the
actors handle constant rewrites? Keep
watching for all the dirty details.
David Milch, the maestro behind "Deadwood,"
came to HBO well into a storied career.
He began writing for "Hill Street Blues" in 1982,
beginning a two-decade run of bringing his dense,
literary style to crime and legal
dramas. His most successful endeavor
to that point was co-creating the
show "NYPD Blue" with Steven Bochco.
By the early 2000s, he was ready to
create a new show using law enforcement
as a window into the way a community is
formed. But the original inspiration was
not the time or place you'd think. In a 2006
interview with American Heritage, Milch said,
"My initial feeling was that I'd set it in
ancient Rome, the time of the emperor Nero."
But HBO already had the series "Rome" in
production, which they felt covered too much of
the same ground. So they asked Milch if he could
explore the same themes of order forming from
chaos, in a different historical setting. Milch
realized that the city of Deadwood, which circa
1876 was a lawless mining camp in Native American
territory, was exactly the setting he needed.
One of the most striking things about
"Deadwood" is its unabashed vulgarity.
Milch didn't specifically set out to dispel
the genteel myths of American Western movies,
but HBO gave him full freedom
to use as much violence,
nudity, and foul language as he needed to depict
his vision of the West as accurately as possible.
"Welcome to f---ing Deadwood."
The language, specifically, became the
most talked-about aspect of "Deadwood"
when it premiered, causing most viewers to
immediately wonder: did they really curse
like that in the real Deadwood? Speaking with NPR,
the curator of Deadwood's Adams Museum admitted,
"The short answer is yes, Deadwood
was a very profane place."
There is ample evidence that all of the
curse words used on "Deadwood" existed at
the time the show is set. Scholar and dictionary
editor Jesse Sheidlower told New York Magazine:
"The evidence that we have
is that they were using more
religious blasphemy than the sexual
insults which are popular today."
But instead of using antiquated terms like
"gol-darn" and "tarnation," Milch and co.
went with language that would be as shocking
to modern audiences as the citizenry intended.
If you're a fan of "Deadwood," you might think
the first role cast was one of the more central,
prominent characters on the show. Who will deliver
the crudely eloquent monologues of Al Swearengen?
Who will embody the simmering rage of Seth
Bullock, or the anxious gentility of Alma Garret?
But a chance encounter in 2002 led to a
small role being the first official casting:
Jewel, the sweet, disabled
cleaning woman at the Gem Saloon.
As actress Geri Jewell told Yahoo! Entertainment,
"I was at Horton & Converse drugstore
in Santa Monica, standing in line.
This man turned around, and he said,
'Oh, my God. Are you Geri Jewell?'"
It was none other than future
"Deadwood" creator David Milch,
who recognized Jewell as Cousin Geri on "The
Facts of Life," a role which broke ground as the
first recurring role for an actor with cerebral
palsy. He promptly asked her to be on the show,
and after one more meeting, the first
member of his sprawling ensemble was cast.
Despite a main cast of well over a dozen, and
hundreds of recurring guest stars, bit parts,
and extras, no actor boosted their reputation more
during the course of "Deadwood" than Ian McShane.
As Al Swearengen, the owner/operator of the Gem
Saloon, McShane was central to the labyrinthian
plot of the show. But surprisingly, the role
wasn't originally written with McShane in mind.
David Milch wrote the role for Ed O'Neill,
best known as Al Bundy on "Married... with
Children." According to O'Neill in
an interview with Erik Hedegaard,
David Milch was so certain on casting
decisions that he assured him,
"You're going to be my Swearengen."
Milch was convinced that O'Neill had the dramatic
chops necessary to overcome his reputation as
a recognizable comedy star. Unfortunately, HBO
hadn't been consulted at all on the decision at
that point. The network wanted to cast someone
as relatively unknown as the rest of the cast,
and suggested McShane. As Milch told C&I Magazine,
"The minute [McShane] walked in, he just took
ownership of the role and my imagination."
The most recognizable "Deadwood" cast
member is almost certainly Keith Carradine.
Known for dozens of Western roles, he was so
well-prepared to play Wild Bill in "Deadwood"
that he brought his own wig, custom made for him
during production of Walter Hill's "Wild Bill."
Speaking with The AV Club, Carradine
says he received a call from Walter Hill,
now set to direct the pilot of "Deadwood,"
who asked him what his hair looked like.
"I said, 'Well, it's short, Walter,
but... I've still got that wig!'"
Reception of his performance was so
positive that HBO initially pushed
back on the character's planned death
in the fourth episode of the show,
matching the timeline of the real Wild
Bill's infamous shooting during a hand
of poker. Carradine recalled his conversation
with Milch at the time to Yahoo! Entertainment:
"[Milch] said, 'the good news
is they love the show […] the
bad news is they don't want me to kill Hickok.'"
Despite the network's note getting his hopes up
for a longer run, Milch won the battle and stuck
to the original plan. The character's presence,
aided by Carradine's pitch-perfect performance,
reverberated throughout
the rest of the show's run.
Praised for its dialogue, plotting, and depth,
the success of "Deadwood" begins
and ends with the writing.
"Could you have been born, Richardson, and
not egg-hatched as I've always assumed?"
And while there was a large
team of writers on the show,
nearly every script was heavily
re-written by showrunner David Milch,
to better fit the rhythm of the language he
heard in his mind — sometimes on the spot.
It wasn't just the writers that had to swallow
their pride — actors needed to adjust to the
demanding task of learning several new pages
of dialogue on the spot. Actor Brad Dourif,
who played fan-favorite Doc Cochran,
recalled a particularly infuriating incident:
"One time he came up to me, and said,
'You see this line?' And he gave me
four pages. 'I'm replacing this line with
this,' and it was a four-page monologue."
Well before "Game of Thrones" gained notoriety
for killing off main characters, "Deadwood" — by
the virtue of its setting and commitment to
authenticity — was the best example of a show
willing to kill off major characters without
warning. It was simply a reality of the West,
and the particular power struggles that came
with being a lawless, frontier mining camp.
Viewers unfamiliar with history were likely
shocked when Wild Bill Hickok was shot and
killed in just the fourth episode of Season 1.
Plenty of characters would succumb to illness,
stabbings, gunfights and more over "Deadwood's"
three seasons and feature-length movie.
"Run for your f---ing life."
Speaking with Inside Pulse during the filming
of Season 2, Jim Beaver shared the anxiety
that he felt over the potential fate of his
character, pure-hearted prospector Ellsworth:
"Everybody on 'Deadwood' is worried
they're going to end up pig chow.
Well, maybe not everybody, but I think
the worriers outnumber the non-worriers!"
Ellsworth was killed by an
assassin at the end of Season 3.
One of the most memorable moments in all of
"Deadwood" is the Season 3 fight between Dan
Dority, played by W. Earl Brown, and villainous
henchman Captain Turner. Milch wanted the fight
to be completely realistic and avoid Western
clichés, or as Brown recounted to Slashfilm:
"No cowboys flying through plate glass."
So the actors and crew found
themselves coordinating a bare-hand,
all-out brawl in the mud of the thoroughfare
with no clue how to end it. Fate intervened
at a poker game Brown was playing with
Alice in Chains guitarist Jerry Cantrell.
Apparently, his brother Dave Cantrell had
once been badly losing a bar fight, when:
"In desperation, he tried to push the
guy off of him. He felt his finger
hit soft tissue and knew without
seeing it, that it was an eyeball."
And so the makers of "Deadwood"
found their way to have Dority,
seemingly about to lose his life, turn the tables
by clawing out Turner's eye in a stroke of luck,
and by far the most intense
visual of the show was born.
Beyond well-known Old West heroes like Wild Bill
and Calamity Jane, many characters in "Deadwood"
were based on real citizens of the historical
city of Deadwood. Central characters like Al
Swearengen, Sol Starr, and Seth Bullock were
based on real people, although many characters
had slightly different fates than their real-life
counterparts. The show’s legacy has driven tourism
to the real Deadwood to such a degree that there
are many specific travel packages designed around
the show and movie. Visitors can experience the
"Deadwood: Heroes & Villains" tour, among others.
You can even get a guided walking
tour from the town's first Marshall,
or at least a re-enactor playing
the part of Con Stapleton,
who was also a character in "Deadwood." While
they welcome visitors, the city's official website
does have an entire section of its website about
differences between the HBO show and real life.
In interviews, time and time again,
the cast recall their time on "Deadwood"
as a head above all the rest. Speaking
with the AV Club, W. Earl Brown recalled
something a fellow actor once told him:
"He said 'I don't really care about money, fame,
and that stuff. What I want to do is something
that has an impact.' [...] And 'Deadwood' was
that for me [...] I think it was, for everyone
involved, something really, really special."
Keith Carradine remarked to the AV Club as well
that it wasn't just the role of Wild Bill Hickok
that attracted him to the part, but the mad genius
behind "Deadwood" that made it more memorable:
"I mean, what a role to have the chance to
play, but especially as written by Milch.
It was extraordinary stuff. He wrote
this kind of American Shakespeare."
Reflecting on returning to her role as
Calamity Jane for "Deadwood: The Movie,"
Robin Weigert told Slashfilm,
"We were getting incredible words to say.
And I knew that I was with an exceptional
cast – that everybody I got to partner
with in scenes was humbling, wonderful."
After a slow-motion death in 2006 — when HBO and
David Milch debated about production schedules,
costs, and the length of a potential
Season 4 for so long that the casts'
contracts expired — there were rumors of everyone
reuniting for one or possibly two wrap-up movies.
But each tii me the plans didn't come to fruition,
it sank the sprawling cast's spirits further until
it seemed all hope was lost. Asked by Vulture if
he ever thought the movie would really happen,
the famously verbose Ian McShane
replied with a curt "No."
Even W. Earl Brown, who for years
maintained a hand-written list of
every main cast member's commitments
for several years just in case,
lost the faith at some point.
In 2019 he told Slashfilm,
"I gave up beating the dead
horse after a few years."
Finally, on the strength of "Deadwood's"
strong DVD sales and streaming legacy,
Milch and HBO struck a deal. "Deadwood:
The Movie" premiered on HBO in 2019,
garnering high praise from both critics and fans.
"What a grand surprise
after such a piece of time."
In 2015, David Milch received a diagnosis
of Alzheimer's. Just months later,
he finally reached an agreement with HBO
to write a script for "Deadwood: The Movie"
and began a four year process of wrapping up
the story. His usual mad rush of re-assembling
sets and scenes on a whim and last-minute rewrites
were tempered by the symptoms of the disease. He
relied more on the director and other producers
to run things on set, and stuck to the script.
But that script was still pure Milch
magic, and writing has proved to be
Milch's best weapon to hold on to his mind
in the face of the disease's progression.
Speaking with Vulture, his wife Rita described
it with an analogy perfect for the legendary TV
creator, who wrote an ensemble cast's
voices like a symphony conductor:
"I compare it to a musician who can still play
and has access to the memory of how to do that
and is still able to exercise his talent. [...]
The brain is David's most exercised muscle."
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one